un año después de las protestas en Gezi, con una ventaja considerable.
Los gobiernos tienen otro tipo de recursos que tienen a su disposición
que no son lo mismo, pero de las diferencias se aprende.
Y como todas las historias de este tipo, aquí no se trata solo de la tecnología.
Es lo que nos permite la tecnología hacer y lo que queremos hacer.
Los movimientos sociales actuales operan de manera informal.
No quieren una dirección institucionalizada.
No se involucran en la política, por temor a la corrupción y cooptación.
Y tienen razón.
Las democracias representativas modernas están asfixiadas en muchos países
por intereses poderosos.
Pero actuar de esta manera hace que sea difícil
una movilización a largo plazo y ejercer presión sobre el sistema
que lleva a los manifestantes frustrados a renunciar
y a más corrupción en la política.
Y la política y la democracia sin un desafío eficaz cojean,
porque las causas que han inspirado
los recientes movimientos modernos son cruciales.
El cambio climático está aquí.
La desigualdad asfixia el crecimiento humano, el potencial y las economías.
El autoritarismo está en las últimas en muchos países.
Necesitamos que los movimientos sean más eficaces.
Ahora, algunas personas han argumentado que el problema
es que los movimientos de hoy en día los forman personas
que no asumen tantos riesgos como antes, y eso no es cierto.
Desde Gezi a Tahrir a otros lugares,
he visto a la gente poner sus vidas y sus medios de vida en juego.
Tampoco es cierto, como afirma Malcolm Gladwell,
que los manifestantes de hoy formar lazos virtuales más débiles.
No, ellos vienen a estas protestas, al igual que antes,
con sus amigos, las redes existentes,
ya veces hacen nuevos amigos de por vida.
Todavía veo a los amigos que me hice
en las protestas globales convocadas ya hace más de una década,
y los vínculos entre extraños tienen valor.
Cuando me rociaron con gas lacrimógeno en Gezi,
la gente que yo no conocía de nada me ayudó y también a los demás,
en lugar de huir.
En Tahrir, vi a personas, los manifestantes,
trabajando muy duro para protegerse entre sí y estar seguros.
Y la sensibilización digital es fantástica porque cambiar mentalidades
es la piedra angular de la evolución de la política.
Pero los movimientos de hoy tienen que ir más allá de la participación a gran escala
y encontrar la manera pensar juntos colectivamente,
desarrollar fuertes propuestas políticas, crear consenso,
averiguar los pasos políticos y relacionarlos para aprovecharlos
porque todas estas buenas intenciones
y la valentía y el sacrificio por sí mismas no van a ser suficientes.
Y se hacen muchos esfuerzos.
En Nueva Zelanda, un grupo de jóvenes están desarrollando una plataforma
llamada Loomio para decisiones participativas a escala.
En Turquía, 140Journos son la celebración de los maratones informáticos
para apoyar a las comunidades así como el periodismo ciudadano.
En Argentina, una plataforma de código abierto llamada DemocracyOS
está ayudando al parlamento y a los partidos políticos.
Estos son todos ejemplos fantásticos, y necesitamos más,
pero la respuesta no será solo una toma de decisiones online.
porque para actualizar la democracia,
vamos a necesitar innovar en todos los niveles,
de lo organizativo a lo político y a lo social.
Debido a que para tener éxito a largo plazo,
a veces hace falta un té sin azúcar
junto a su Twitter.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)